missionnait à la Ligue depuis 4 ans pour
entraîner et
gérer un centre d'entraînement au sein
de la ligue donc ça c'est une émission
principale
cette structure d'accueil qui était
essentiellement basée sur les jeunes
avec des championnats de France en
objectif
c'est orienté vers la préparation des
Jeux des îles avec un accueil plus large
des sportifs
on est parti de d'un niveau très
hétérogène avec des personnes qui
avaient déjà une expérience de la régate
et d'autres pas du tout aujourd'hui on
se retrouve avec un niveau homogène avec
des axes de travail qui sont différents
et sur lesquels on a hâte de
continuer à évoluer pour réussir à faire
des belles choses au jeu des îles
ouais je suis sur mon bateau moteur avec
mon chapeau ma casquette et puis bah je
les observe analyse leur réussite ou
leur défaite et puis derrière ressortir
une bonne conclusion pour que il
progresse mais ils peuvent pas être là
du lundi au vendredi à faire du bateau
et c'est vrai que comparé à nos voisins
c'est chez lois il y a certains
navigateurs qui sont payés à l'année
pour faire du laser pour suivre la World
Cup là du championnat du monde en laser
et c'est vrai que nous on doit quand on
va sur l'eau on évite de perdre du temps
il me semble que la voile c'est le seul
sport de nature représenté au jeu des
îles le seul sport sur sur l'océan
Indien le sol sport qui qui réussit à
montrer aux Réunionnais que on peut
continuer à s'éclater sur l'océan
qu'il y a des jeunes qui a des adultes
et puis que tout le monde kiffe être sur
le site
merci à toi